Samantha is with us in Tampa Florida hi
Samantha how are you I'm great thank you
thank you for taking my call
I am a stay home mom of six kids and I
just am in the process of getting term
life insurance on myself and my question
is is how much as a stay-at-home mom
should I be getting and two of my six
kids are from my first marriage and so
on tears if there's a percentage that I
should leave for them and leave the rest
under my husband what would happen to
them if something happened to you but
they're 21 and 18 so technically I would
probably just kind of on their own yeah
no you don't need to I mean if you
wanted to if you want to if you want to
leave them some actual money a little
bit you could should something happen to
you but I don't I mean it would just be
a little bit of a you know twenty thirty
thousand bucks or something to get
started right but not they don't need
big chunks of money because they know
they're able-bodied and they'll be fine
and they're like virtually grown so what
we tell folks again is we're trying to
replace the lost income in your case you
don't have an income but you provide a
service that would have to be replaced
in other words your husband's got your
husband's got a car mary poppins right I
mean he will because the other are
twelve ten nine and eight yeah I mean we
not only have nanny but we have car
service
we have laundry service and we have meal
service right so you know if you wanted
to hire Mary Poppins you know you
probably could find her for somewhere
around forty thousand dollars a year
right now and so if you did that you'd
say well I want four hundred thousand on
you what's your husband make he didn't
felt 150-160 was honest I put I put I'd
put four hundred five hundred on you and
that way he could use the income off of
that literally to replace
not the heart obviously not the care of
a mom but the duties that a mom does
right okay it takes for you take 40
$50,000 a year to do that I mean we're
talking maid service and taxi service
and tutoring yeah and you know and
laundry and food and whatever else you
know I mean it's nanny so you know you
start by adding that you got some you
got some help here he's going to need or
his incomes going to go down because
he's going to be home more and it's
gonna affect his career definitely go
down and I'd want us to be able to pay
off the house which is our only debt at
this point yeah what do you all in the
house 176 yeah okay yeah that'd be fine
I mean again four or five hundred on you
would be fine given that he makes 150
and so he needs a million and a half to
two million on him and somewhere in that
range and just check Xander insurance
and get you a deal on some term life
insurance and then later on when the
kids are grown and gone you know and
you've got a big pile of money and the
house is paid off we went to worry about
any of this you can drop the insurance
you become self-insured at that point